i saw a bit of black swan they got
really bored and they turned on yeah a
lot of
i mean both of those movies are heavily
heavily influenced yeah yeah i saw that
black swan was heavily inspired
it's funny that you fell asleep during
that one because black swan is basically
the same
storyline i think i was on a plane and
you know sometimes you're in a mood
where you're like i don't want to watch
a movie but
what else can i do yeah and i think i
put blacks one on i was like it was not
the right environment to watch black
spots
like very dark 10-inch lcd those shitty
packed nuts you know i
have this genre i like to call plane
movies yeah where it's like movies you
would never
ever watch but when you're in a plane
you're like everyday stays in the mood
yeah yeah basically every mission
impossible i'm pretty sure
his career on the rocks korea are so
solely being funded by planes
like no one why else would you watch
that [ __ ] shark movie that jason
stated the same way
it's shark movie the whole movie was him
fighting a shark
what what was the movie called are you
serious is it is this is this
it's on the screen right now sharknado 4
it's just a movie and i i can't describe
any of it to you it's just the whole
thing was just this really
jason statham it's like imagine
imagine jaws on steroids and that was
like the whole movie it was something so
it wasn't calling megalon that was like
mega something no
mega
yeah there's just too much [ __ ] oh my
god so many movies but yeah yeah
stay at the movies yeah no i agree with
the aeroplane movies thing i've i've
seen
more movies on planes than i think i
have
in like cinemas and my own room yeah i
feel bad for anything i watch on a plane
because i feel like it automatically
loses two points
out of ten right just because i watch it
on a plane no no no i mean like i never
have a positive memory of [ __ ] watching
a series sometimes
sometimes i just want to [ __ ] watch
some shitty thing like yeah have you
ever had like
before playing like you you download
something you actually want to watch
yeah like an anime or a series of manga
and you're like
i don't really feel like watching let me
watch this shitty 5 out of 10
show that's or movie that i would never
watch under any other circumstances
that's even worse because i go on a
plane being
like okay i can work on a script because
i have my laptop
on a plane no okay i i plan to every
single time
okay i'm gonna like work on a script or
i'm gonna play this game i'm gonna
finish it while i'm on this 10 hour
flight to the us
but instead no i'm gonna watch this
really crap documentary
about this topic that i just do not care
about but because you're forced
to watch it by the end of it i'm just
like you know that was very informative
i learned a lot i'm glad i watched that
people looking like work on planes
i don't know how they can do it you're
on are you doing on domestic flights
oh okay you're a [ __ ]
[Applause]
it's weird right because with airplane
movies as you said
yeah as you said like it's always like
two points lower than if you were to
watch it because it's not a comfortable
viewing race no it's not
which is all the more reason why i want
to re-watch makia
because i watched makia on a flight the
[ __ ] is makia
i would never watch an anime film that i
want to watch
on a flight yeah i i remember hearing
people watching your name
when it was like out in theaters yeah
and the only chance they had to watch it
was on the flight and i'm just like oh i
feel so sorry for you
i know and like that's the exact same
experience i had with makia because
i missed it in the cinemas uh before i
went to the us
but it was on my flight to the us i was
like perfect i could finally watch it
yeah in my head i was like oh no i have
to watch it on this tiny
screen with these crappy ass headphones
that i had because i didn't bring my
proper headphones
but i watched it on the flight man i
cried like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my god which makes me more
like it makes me more inclined to go
watch it on like a big screen yeah yeah
because i know if i watched it on the
big screen
i would be crying even more like you
just get a text from like row
three i like c that's like why you
crying so damn loud
like that meme template you know
but yeah if you if you don't know do you
know mark yeah yeah i know i know i do
so makia is this movie that was it
wasn't advertised anywhere
no no no it was it was very under the
radar i think it was like pa
was it by paw works no it's not paw
works it was written and directed by
okadamari yeah yeah what is it about
she she did um anahana oh okay yeah
she's basically known as the anime
writer who is known for like all those
series that cry yeah she's like the
master of making you cry
and makia was the movie that it was a
first directing debut
but the thing is it wasn't advertised
anywhere like
even in japan it wasn't advertised
anywhere and i only found out about it
because my friend nabi
yeah you know about it but he let me
know like two days before it was gone
from the cinema so i was like
cool i guess i can't watch that but then
it was on the flight and yeah
but that's the thing right like when you
watch something that's really funny
or that very emotional on a plane yeah
you can't just
burst out well you can [ __ ] cry
dude i i've cried so i was literally
doing like
like
and i didn't want this like white guy
sitting next to me to think like what
the [ __ ] this guy's crying
like a cartoon yeah what's wrong with
you but